Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan.
Today, I want to introduce you to a
relatively recent open source project that is going
to change the way
you handle your Kubernetes networking policies
and more.
That project is called Otterize.
It's got a complete evolution on the way
that we configure networking
access within our clusters
using something called
iBack,
intent based access control.
And we're gonna dive into what that means
in just a moment.
Now like I said, Otterize is different.
It isn't a service mesh.
It doesn't change your pods, inject in proxies
and sidecars
to order to control your traffic.
Instead, it integrates
with Kubernetes,
Kafka,
Istio,
configuring the tools that you're already using in
your cluster,
but providing a better DX
to allow you to do that as a
dev team.
To understand more,
let's dive in to what iBack actually means.
So here we have the Otterize website.
You can find us at authorize.com,
and the page we're looking at right now
is the iBack page slash iBack.
Now intent based access control is a declarative
way that allows you to define which services
are allowed to call other services within your
cluster.
Traditionally, the way that this would be handled
or at least what I've seen from working
with many organizations
is that the developers don't focus at all
on security
or policy.
Especially in a micro service environment
where teams are responsible for one or more
services,
they really only flow together enough YAML for
a deployment and a service within the cluster.
All of the security and policy happens from
some sort of SRE,
DevOps, or platform team, or if your organization
is lucky enough to have one, a security
team.
Now this means that we have a violation
of the law of demeanor.
The law of demeanor really just means that
we don't want leaky extractions.
We don't really want our security platform DevOps
teams to have to understand the entirety of
a microservice architecture
to be able to put together these security
policies
because inevitably, they're gonna get it wrong or
it's just gonna be a lot harder than
it should be.
And if we're gonna provide a declarative way
to define
all of this access,
why not allow the developers to do it?
Picture this, you're working on a service.
You write the code that makes a network
call.
It wants to speak to Kafka,
consume a topic, publish to a topic, or
perhaps even make a gRPC or HTTP request
to another service.
You wrote the code.
You know what the intent is.
You intend for your service to communicate
or speak to another service.
So why not log those intents
inside of your repository
right next to your service?
And that's what iMac wants to change.
Using something called the intense file,
which is really just a Kubernetes resource, a
custom resource.
You can see that my service,
using this example here, the checkout service,
calls these other services.
Now where this extends beyond
what we're familiar with with traditional Kubernetes networking
policies
is that there's some l seven awareness baked
into what Otterize can do.
So you can see here that we define
the HTTP requests are allowed on this path
with these methods.
Taking us even further to something you can't
do with network policies in Kubernetes
is here we have a Kafka intent
which allows us to produce messages, write messages
on a topic called orders.
This is very fine grained ACL that needs
to be configured on the Kafka broker itself,
and Otterize
can make that happen.
So that's enough chat. Let's get hands on.
In this demo, we're going to install Otterize.
I'm going to show you how to add
enough intents
for Otterize to create Kubernetes network and policies
for you. Otterize allows you
to ease in to use an Otterize, and
we'll take a look at how we can
run Otterize
in shadow mode and enforcement mode
Before finally taking a look at Otterize Cloud,
which will allow us to visualize
and build a map topology
of all of the services
and their access permissions within our cluster.
Let's dive right in. Okay. So let's install
Otterize into our cluster.
Here, we have the Otterize organization
on GitHub with a repository called HelmChart,
which, you guessed it, has their HelmChart.
Right now, we are gonna focus on Otterize
Kubernetes.
This will actually install all the other charts
into your cluster, given your complete authorized deployment.
Just to cover what these other charts are,
the intense operator is what takes your intense
custom resource and creates policies and ACLs with
other software running in your cluster.
The network mapper
just maps the services within your cluster
to understand the way the traffic flows and
allows you to generate a diagram to visualize
that.
So the first thing we need to do
is add the helm repository,
like so.
Next, we can install
Otterize.
Easiest thing I've done all day.
Let's just get that two moments
and done.
Now, we can run, kubectl,
authorize system,
get pods.
And we'll see each of those components spinning
up.
Let's crack on.
Okay. So let's take a look at what's
running inside of our cluster.
Here we have the Weaveworks Sockshop
demo.
This is a sample store built with multiple
microservices
and a whole bunch of services that allow
them to communicate with one another.
We also have the front end exposed on
our load balancer service,
meaning
we can browse it.
We can view products
and view the cart.
If we click login,
we get a dialogue, and if we click
register,
we get a dialogue.
If we open login again,
we can type user
and password,
and login successful.
So
let's use an authorized intense file
to make the communication between these services more
explicit.
Okay. So let's, first of all, log out.
Then we'll jump back to Versus Code where
we have an empty intense dot YAML.
Gonna paste in an example resource that works
for this demo.
Here, we define an authorized client intense
with whatever name you wish. Of course, if
it makes sense, bonus points.
We then define a spec where we say
that we want to
specify
the intents for the front end service.
The front end service being the application that
runs on our browser, the web app, which
is likely going to call pretty much every
service. But right now, we're only gonna make
explicit that it calls the user service.
So we can come to the CLI
and apply our intents dot YAML.
And what's going to happen now is that
the intents operator
is gonna detect the custom resource
and create a network policy.
We can describe
that network policy,
and we will see that it specifies a
pod selector
where the server is user SockShopE8BOA2.
It then has an allow ingress
from a pod selector where there is a
label
which allows access
to user stock ShopEBBOA2
true.
Now the intense operator behind the scenes is
resolving
the service names and our client intents
and allocating the labels to facilitate the traffic.
If we jump back
to the web browser
and hit refresh,
saying we wish to log in,
it works.
Now, of course, all we've done is allow
traffic.
We haven't blocked
any traffic.
So let's head back over to our intents.yaml
where we can add a protected service.
Here, we're going to see that this user
service is protected,
which means
all traffic
that doesn't have an intent
will be blocked.
We can now come back over here and
apply our updated intents dot YAML
and run NetPol again.
We'll now see that three seconds ago,
a default deny user network policy,
which does not allow any ingress,
targets, user service.
We can now come back over to the
sock shop
where we can ask it
to log in.
Success.
So let's make one more change.
We're now going to update our front end
intents and instead of the user service,
we'll see
that it's allowed to communicate with the order
service.
Our network policies
will now be updated.
We now have access to orders from Sock
Shop and still are default to die on
a user service.
Meaning,
we come back to log in for the
third time.
No success.
That's because our browser is now unable to
communicate
with
the user
service
To the point
where we've crashed the Weaveworks sock shop demo.
Let's come back
and add another service
for our front end
to speak to
the user service.
We can add a kubectl apply
and tense.
Get net pull
and try to log in again.
Success.
So let's protect one more service.
We'll copy our protect service
and paste.
This time, we're going to protect the catalog
service.
Now no client intent specify that they call
the service.
Meaning, we will get a new default deny
network policy
for the catalog service.
So let's come back here and refresh
the sock shop.
And as you can see,
most of the services are working,
including login and logout.
However,
there are no products available on the homepage.
And that's how intent files and protected services
work with Otterize.
This two phase approach to defining how your
services communicate means that you can
adopt Otterize
step by step.
You can add all of your client intents
without ever breaking any traffic within your cluster.
As you have comfort that your intents cover
most of your traffic or all of your
traffic ideally,
you can begin to protect your services one
by one.
Now there is a better way
to do this
using Otterize Cloud.
Let's take a look. Otterize Cloud is a
SaaS product with a very generous free tier.
This should satisfy most of you watching this
video.
The benefits of using the cloud
and the Otterize provide visual understanding
of your intents
and the enforcement.
So let's log in.
The first thing we need to do is
connect our cluster.
We can give this a name like so,
and we'll call this environment production.
This gives you the helm commands that you
need to run to connect to Otterize Cloud.
I'm saying no to authorize already to be
installed on my cluster because I did a
helm delete prior to this step.
But if you do have it installed, it's
fine.
Authorize cloud is just a value add on.
We also get to decide whether we wish
to be in enforcement mode or shadow.
We're going to leave enforcement mode off.
This means we'll be using the protected service
custom resource that you've seen a moment ago.
Of course, if you wish to delete enforcement
mode,
the protected services will not be required.
Let's copy the helm install
command.
Like so.
We can now see that our network mapper,
the intense operator, and the credentials operator
will begin to say connected.
Some may take longer than the rest.
If we pop over to the CLI,
we can run get pods.
When all of these are running, we will
have a visual topology map of all the
services running in our cluster.
Let's come back in a moment.
So here is the access graph.
This shows us the services within our cluster
and the communication patterns
as well as whether the access would be
allowed or denied.
We can see the front end wants to
speak to orders and user.
User is protected, and the traffic is allowed.
Whereas our front end, currently traffic is allowed,
but that's because the service is unprotected.
Now this only shows the services
that have client intents,
but there is a network mapper feature
of Otterize.
So let's go browse
around the website
just to give it a little traffic to
analyze
and jump back to our access graph.
And already,
we can see services
popping up within our cluster.
So let's filter on our SOC shop namespace.
And we can see now that our front
end speaks to
cars, user, orders, catalog, session DB.
Our queue master speaks to rabbit
and our catalog speaks to the database. The
orders has its own database. The user has
a database and the cart has a database.
We can now see all the traffic
scanned by Otterize.
So we can see at the moment our
front end is not allowed to speak to
catalog because
we protected the service without an intent.
And now our catalog currently can speak to
its database, however, is because it's an unprotected
service.
So let's change that.
Let's add that our front end
speaks
to the catalog
and also allow our catalog
speak to the catalog
DB,
like so.
Now the catalog is the only service that
speaks to the catalog DB,
so we're gonna protect that too.
Like so.
Now,
we do a cube control apply,
intense.
And if we come back to our access
graph,
in real time, it's going to reload
and show us the changes
through our intents
and our protected services.
We can now see
that our front end speaks to the catalog
and just protect it, and the catalog speaks
to the catalog DB,
and it's also protected.
The ideal situation.
But what about the rest of our services?
So here we are in the command line
again.
And you'll be pleased to know that Otterize
have a CLI.
The CLI
allows you to work with the network mapper
where you can list
all the services
and the communication.
You can even
visualize
setting
an output path
like so.
We can now open
our PNG and
get a visualization of everything without Otterize Cloud.
But I think we can all agree
the cloud's a bit nicer.
So let's run
network map export,
which dumps out all of the YAML that
you need
to map your intents
and overwrite our intents dot YAML.
We can now apply this directly to our
cluster,
and we can ignore the intents that already
exist.
Let's come back to our access graph, which
will reload in real time.
Now all the warrants disappear,
and we can protect the services
that we wish to protect.
And that is pretty cool.
So I hope you have enjoyed what you've
seen.
Otterize is pretty sweet. It's an open source
project that allows your developers to write client
intents next to the code itself.
Services
could be protected or enforced by default.
You can use the network mapper to scan
your cluster as it is right now and
export a huge amount of YAML into your
repository.
You can visualize it with the CLI
or who can to authorize cloud
for that nicer experience.
So go check it out.
Until next time, have a great day.